now I want to throw back to uh to Tucker
Carlson and Dave Portnoy because they
talked about uh the Trump and Biden age
thing and something surprising came up
here like I thought Trump should have
done I thought he should done the debate
yeah like to me if you're voting on the
president you want to hear him debate
he's brilliant he's the best to ever
play the political game so to become
president I think it was the right move
not to do it but for the bedroom of the
country I think you should be on the
door I kind of agree I like the debates
personally I mean how else are people
going to decide the problem is that the
news companies that host the debates are
so rotten and corrupt and everybody
knows it the whole thing's wrong the
whole thing is rotten and corrupt is
Biden going to be the nominee
ID
don't know I'm not a political person
but I feel like there's been a shift
where internally maybe the Democrats
don't think he can win and they're
setting the stage to do somebody else uh
I think it's crazy if he's I mean
to be honest I think both Trump and Bina
are too old I think there should I don't
think you should be able to be that old
and be president but I think Trump
100 more aware I mean I I think Biden
has got some serious dementia issues
like how that is the president I don't
know and that's not a Democrat because I
said about both it's like uh Mitch Mitch
the guy who had the stroke doing the
speech the other day Mitch McConnell
yeah like what how how are
these people running our country you
wouldn't put those these people I would
say in McConnell's the only defense I
would say of Mitch McConnell is
McConnell post-stroke is an improvement
over McConnell pre-stroke
um fair enough fair enough fair enough
there's no companies in the world where
I would buy stock where you're having
the CEO seemingly at that event it's
just only in politics it's crazy yeah
it's because it's only the world yeah
not a big deal not a big deal at all and
it's broken so
I agree 100 that's the interesting thing
about that right like it's one thing for
Dave Portnoy to say okay Biden and Trump
are both old the fact that Tucker who is
largely in the Trump Camp of course
right I think he likes DeSantis too
that's fairly obvious and they had that
sit down right before I went off the
grid that was what middle of July uh
when they did that that conference with
the Blaze and Tucker sat down with all
of the candidates and and you could see
that clearly Tucker liked a lot of what
DeSantis was saying
um DeSantis by the way 45 years old if
I'm not mistaken uh but for Tucker to
say I agree 100 neither one of these
guys should be running because they're
too old that's pretty powerful as Brock
said as we showed you that clip uh it's
surprising that that clip didn't go more
viral because that's Tucker who's it
it's not that he's purely a trump
supporter as I'm saying but he is a
major mouthpiece for let's say the Mago
movement basically saying hey head of
Maga shouldn't even be running that is
that is pretty powerful